hey guys dr. Burke here in this video
we're going to discuss some pretty
deadly hidden toxins that are basically
it's affecting us all okay I don't know
if you know this but the u.s. is the
largest exporter of banned pesticides in
the world you know that yeah certain
companies in America basically sell and
pesticides severely restricted by the US
you can't use them in the US you can
sell them you can't use them to
third-world countries okay and for
example DDT was banned in 1972 okay well
we we can make it and then we ship it to
other countries another one called DPC
dbcp was banned in 1977 because it
caused with sterility and cancer but
we're allowed to sell it so each year we
sell about a billion pounds of this
toxic waste crap to other countries and
may you say you might say well as long
as we're not getting exposed right well
look what happens the u.s. sells of
stuff which is non real it's not
regulated by the EPA because we're not
using it to a third world country third
world country uses it on their farms
they probably don't even know that it's
been banned in the u.s. it's on their
food fruits vegetables right guess where
we get our fruit in the winter boom
comes right back to the US so when
something says it's from a third world
country it's now grow in America you
have to realize that it could
potentially be sprayed by some chemical
that's banned it gets into our
bloodstream I'm going to put some links
down below just to talk about that just
so you can see that even our bodies now
are exposed are still being exposed to
things that were banned 20 30 40 years
ago okay pretty scary
all right on that positive note I guess
what you can do is increase awareness
and also share this video and and just
make sure that you
consume food that's actually grown
within America all right I'll see the
next video hey guys thank you so much
for watching please click the subscribe
button and I will see you in the next
video